he's in China because he already thinks
of himself as the president okay he I
have no doubt that eventually it'll come
to a point where the Democratic party
has decided no no no this is the person
you need to vote for anyone who speaks
out against him is the enemy I would
just say that his leadership in
California is good reason to brush him
off for the loser that he really is okay
you're over there in China talking about
fenel right how about you clean up your
own house how about you take a look at
what's happening with the prosecutions
or lack of prosecutions of the drug
traffickers in your state he can't be
bothered to deal with that right he
can't be bothered to deal with the
absolute degenerate garbage that comes
out of his administration instead he's
going to China pretending as if
everything he's been doing in California
is great and he's a great leader who you
know has that road paved for him to be
president